we
so consciousnesses is one of the deepest
questions in science and I think
consciousness way may very well be the
deepest questions and one of the deepest
mysteries science has ever cooked with
and this is one reason by the way that
neuroscience is a very unique field in
all of Sciences so neuroscience is the
only field in which the thing or the
organ being studied is also doing this
study now this raises a number of
potential concerns right this is that
even possible 10 a device or an organ or
a computational system understand itself
and that's what we're asking our brains
to do when we're faced with problems
such as the nature of consciousness and
the nature of consciousness is is
extremely hard to study for neuroscience
and science because it's very hard to
measure but some people have proposed or
believed that one of the reasons
consciousness involved is to allow us to
simulate future scenarios and this
relates to something called mental time
travel so mental time travel is the
ability that we have to relive past
experiences so we've all spent perhaps
inordinate amounts of time daydreaming
about the past or reliving things that
have happened and giving those things
alternate endings and simulating them in
the past to see how we can use them in
the future we also spend a lot of time
that day dreaming about the future and
importantly our ability to mentally
project ourselves in the future is
perhaps one of the most valuable things
about those most valuable cognitive
abilities of our species I think in many
ways a future-oriented time travel makes
Homo sapiens sapiens
it makes Homo sapiens wise because it's
what gives us the ability to engage in
endeavors that other animals cannot do
so if you think about something as as a
signature of our species making a tool
making a tool carving
a blade out of an obsidian stone is is
something that implicitly requires a
thought of the future it means I'm doing
something for something in the future so
I have a purpose for that similarly what
perhaps our most important inventions of
humankind is agriculture this notion of
planting a scene needs today and reaping
its benefits or assuring a source of
food in the future is is one thing that
drove our species forward and that again
is something that makes that requires
mental time travel that requires our
ability to think in the distant future
[Music]
you